hello everybody Thank You Nico and the
Google Play team for giving me the
toughest sport in the agenda we are all
coming back from a heavy lunch so it's
gonna be difficult to engage you but
since it's a session about engagement
let's try so since we have very little
time I don't want to spend too much time
on this slide you can research about us
you can download our app but the one
thing I want you to remember about a
being English is very simple we teach
English which is actually a very simple
sentence that eyes the complexity what
we do see when you try to work improving
engagement sometimes you feel the
barrier of maybe not trying to really
achieve the final result that your user
is trying to reach put it simple the
final goal for our users is to learn a
language can we really measure the fact
that the user is progressing in learning
language with the classic matrix that we
have for engagement so basically a few
years ago we were asking ourselves this
question is quantitative data enough for
us to measure the efficiency over metal
is stickiness or 1 day 7 day retention
the right metric for us to measure that
and I want to ask you a question I think
we are all obsessed with metrics how
many of you have checked your KPIs in
the last 24 hours
come on guys you should do better the
other question for you is how many of
you had a meaningful conversation with
one of your customer in the last month
I'm a complete surprise I see this is
the point we came to the realization
that quantitative data was able to tell
us where the problem was
but to really go further we needed to go
to the real source and so we decided to
change completely our mentality
and to really put our student first -
it's been a long journey for us and we
are still off withdrew to become a real
customer centric company but still is a
journey I want to share with you and the
first step that for us was very
important to go through this journey was
to really have management commitment is
very hard if management doesn't believe
in this statement to be able to become a
customer centric company the second
thing we had to do with luckily we had
this support but the second thing we had
to do was to basically shock the
organization and to do that we literally
brought people out of the building yes
literally we took people from different
departments engineering marketing
product of course we went on the street
and we started interviewing potential
customers and something I invite you to
do also because for us was a very
mind-blowing experience and the results
we got back from that experience was
that we stopped discussing what we
thought was better for a user and the
conversation slowly started becoming
more oriented to what the user will do
where user will need in this moment
sometimes you don't need to do to go
that far you have probably the answer
already in the ass your customer support
team is in the front line they know
already what are the main issues of your
users so simply ask them another
important step for us was to introduce
user research now we do research every
week we have users coming every week in
the office with the remote surveys we do
a lot of stuff that allows us to have a
two ways communication with our users
and another very important part is
trying to avoid silos sometimes this
information like in the case of customer
support is already available it's only
compartmentalized
into department someone has someone else
had you need to make this information
available if you really want to focus on
customers to improve engagement and we
brought this up into our development
cycle so basically you can read
a lot about dual-track agile I highly
recommend an article from more or less
ten years ago from Marty Kagan
from the Silicon Valley for the group
that explains a lot about the
methodology but the basic concept is you
have basically two tracks in Discovery
you try to figure out what to build in
delivery you deliver what you ready
validated and so having our process or
development process considering these
two different moments there are both a
tentative moments was key for us because
in Discovery we use techniques like the
science prints prototyping research to
quickly validate hypotheses to formulate
and validate hypotheses and thanks to
the palliative data we get from this
first phase we can more confidently move
into delivery also engineering teams are
more happy at this point because their
probability of what they are building in
the delivery track is higher because we
already validated kiai potus's in this
covering so to give an idea and trying
to also jump into a real life example of
how we had to leverage qualitative data
in combination we consider you want look
at this very simple step in our old
morning so again we teach English so in
your boarding stage we were asking users
to tell us what was their initial level
of English if we look at only
quantitative data we weren't losing so
many users in the step actually parylene
nobody was dropping off at this point
every user was selecting a level but you
know what when we started analyzing
their sentiment in this stage we
discover that many user will actually
frustrated how do I assess my level of
English and now this is gonna work out
at the end for me in the app what we
found out is that eventually the fact
that users were randomly selecting level
of English in this stage led to
abandonment later on we have users that
were overestimating their level and
there were
basically facing with two difficult
exercises and vice-versa users that were
under estimating themselves and finding
the exercises we're proposing too easy
for them so we worked in a solution we
prototype different solutions to try to
address this issue and at the end we
went for one day was kind of
counterintuitive we created a way longer
funnel during the onboarding now we
asked users to take a level test yes we
still have easy pad if you're a beginner
if you want to skip the onboarding you
can still do that but our new happy path
for users from boarding the app goes
through a level test and again it's
country intuitive because we were adding
many steps in you in your Indian
boarding process you will think ok many
more steps the funnel will be longer and
you will lose users well it wasn't that
the case in fact what we saw overall
with these and all other experiments we
did on your boarding is that we achieved
double activation in our app and again
if you are only to focus on the
quantitative data we're never gonna
discover where the real problem was so
again what we learn as a company is that
you need to go to the source you need to
talk with your customers eventually even
going out to the building complement
quantitative data with qualitative data
bring it into your full development
cycle make it practice for you to have
this feedback into your development
cycle and ultimately experiment
experiment a lot because at the end is
what really is going to help you find
the successful solutions thank you I'm
gonna pass the baton to reach it a way
to sail it right thank you
you
okay good afternoon everyone I'm rich it
from true caller so what is true color
quick view on that true color is a
communication app that improves not only
your calls but also your messages we've
been around for a while we're
headquartered in Sweden the main thing
to get from this is that our context is
that we are operating at a certain scale
we were able to do some of these things
because we operate at that scale so
talking about engagement the first thing
is how did we measure the engagement
there are a bunch of metrics that we can
use we looked at you know sessions per
dau time spent but then we stuck to
Dhamma ratio this was the North Star
metric that we're using now this is the
email that goes out to all employees
across the company every single day
we we do have feature level metrics as
well of course for engagement but we
thought this was a good overall
overarching metric to track it also gave
us a comparison with some of the other
apps so we said that let's stick to this
one so that's how we measured but what
did we do to increase our engagement so
the first thing was we realized we made
this mistake many times as we were
launching new things we realized that a
lot of our users didn't even know that
we had launched some of these things so
we made the effort introducing some of
these features to them we also ensured
that we got users to upgrade to the
latest version of the app which was
spoken about in the last session as well
this made a huge difference to us here
is another example of education that we
used we sent out notification slightly
contextual so that we don't spam our
users the other one thing that we did
which I don't think is spoken about
enough it did come up in the earlier
session was speed if if you can improve
your app launch speed just that exact
metric app launch speed you
can easily get a few percentage points
at the very least of your engagement
I mean faster apps are much easier to
engage with and that's what users love
so please focus on speed if that's
something you can do and please focus on
your app open speed and then we did we
looked at how is it that we can add more
features what where should we look at
four more features for engagement and
this is about going deeper into your
existing use case so we were already
there in in the users life for calls
when you get an incoming call we showed
you caller ID or we told you it was spam
and that's great so we said how can we
participate even further into that
calling experience so that's when we
built the dialing experience inside so
we went deeper into the calling space
the other thing we did was while you can
go deeper as well we also looked at
slightly adjacent parallel use cases so
we were already in the calling space and
we were doing really well users loved
what we were doing and we said that's
similar problem they were solving in the
calling space actually exists in the
messaging space as well so maybe we can
go horizontal and introduce messaging
and I think this was one of our biggest
gains in engagement that we went
horizontal and our users love that the
other thing we we found was all our apps
everyone has some user base in some
community that it's that that is already
using your app use that community to
further create engagement in your apps
so we had features like tagging which is
on the screen commenting spam reporting
we took all of the you know community
generated content and we put this back
into the app so we actually showed other
users that this number has 56 spam
reports and this this many people have
tagged it as this and that actually gave
this feeling to the rest of our users
that the app is alive and it's active
and it's meant to be engaged with so our
community engagement actually drove
further engagement as well
all of this resulted in really good
gains for us when we focused on it 30%
increase in that dama ratio not strong
metric for us so that's great
a lot of things went well you know 30
percent increase
I got a pat on my back as well but we we
were hurt in in many different ways and
here are some examples of that the first
one was so we educated our users we
pushed them to learn new features that
we have but we really annoyed our users
we were hammered in the App Store for
our ratings and reviews and we had to
pause our roadmap to focus on some of
these things and that really hurt us so
be careful when you're educating users
that you don't go overboard they keep
track of these things closely also what
happened was while we were focused on
this not strong metric we started
ignoring the key stats that are
available on Android vitals that was
there in the earlier session
specifically crash rate wakelocks these
things hurt us also uninstall rates went
up our ratings went down so always when
you're adding new stuff please make sure
you're tracking android vitals as well
because we've learned the hard way that
it really makes a difference the third
one is I mean you can obsess about this
metric any metric with some Knox or
metric for your app but don't get
obsessed like don't make your roadmap
obsessed with that metric because what
will then start happening is you'll
forget that users actually don't give a
about your engagement they care
about their life and how you're
improving their life you have to keep
adding stuff that adds value to your
users otherwise your competitors will go
ahead of you you will where you want to
take your users strategically you will
lose out on those aspects so I would say
I think the theme of this talk is is
exactly what I should end with that you
should do less do it better and I think
that's what will likely get you more and
with that I will hand over to Tim Oh
from Badou
[Applause]
hello everyone
Thank You Gina and Rasheed for great
presentation my name is Timur I'm from
Badu to give a few little bit more
contexts but it's not about one app but
it was a group of dating apps one of our
biggest brands is by do obviously and
Bumble but we also have like chappie
which is like dating up for gays and
lumen which is dating up for seniors
like over over 50s so like a lot of
different brands with the same dating
mechanic inside our business is like
huge we have 1 billion worlds plays per
day in our group we have 460 million
users registered around vApp so what we
by far the biggest dating group in the
world and we have working 300 thousand
users registered daily so engagement and
like how to make rain gauge and smart
and doing mobile s is like in our hearts
like it's what driving our business
forward so like what I decided to do is
like to give you some examples over
features which we launched recently and
how they affected our car keep your eyes
and like how by looking differently in
this keep your eyes you cannot take
different decisions and I want to start
with feature which is sending calling
send heart and chat so I charted our
core functionality we have chats in all
of our apps and we decided that probably
like users have a problem if sending the
message like we're spending too much
time like thinking about what should be
send like how we should approach for
people first and we want to give them
like easy experience like I said ok like
let's give me a swan bottle but hearts
and you just sending this heart and you
invite person to a conversation like
great feature like we launched this one
results was quiet like controversial so
like obviously like a lot of people
sending mischance like number of
messages now ecosystem rose for like 20
percent like everyone sending chance to
everyone everyone initiated shot like
easily but when we started to dig deep
into these metrics we find out what
reply rate for these messages was
ridiculously low so
for males like compared to a normal
messages is what six percent down
for females like they don't respond to
his messages like ignoring this one so
obviously like we don't like people
ignoring the messages we don't like
people in knots focusing on initiating
which arts be focusing on of a
meaningful charts and like our main
metrics like female retention like
started to go down like females not only
didn't like to reply these messages but
they didn't like with flooding of white
cards so much but wave living rough so
we decided to iterate on this one and
launch menu feature like what if you go
instead of giving you a easy access to
sending message what it will go for
backwards and actually will disallow you
to send message and make it much much
harder so we launched a feature which is
called bed openers blocker so if you'll
see that like you're sending us some bad
message like hey oh hi he's saying okay
like this one message this message
probably bad like and this one is not
open with a good conversation results
was obvious this fish was launched and
Bumble which calf unique mechanic words
only females can initiate with charts
obviously this feature like drop-down
initiating chats ratio like six percent
messages like six and females like
initiating the charts but reply right
from his messages rolls like 14 percent
and we have this metric which is called
meaningful chart it's like how much
messages was send like what was the
reply rates like all of war it's giving
us overall score of equality on my chart
it's a lot seven percent so by sending
less messages we actually improve the
consistent for users by actually like
sending more meaningful messages and
exchanging like in more meaningful
conversations I will transfer more
complex examples and the first one is
push push messages controlled by
algorithm so rigid rows so I can't have
like very very interesting topic about
that sometimes you don't know are you
over 25 users are you annoying enough
what we're is like borderline between
being annoying and like mattify enough
users what because we want users may be
notified about very important events in
our system so we decided with like
probably were humans and manual manual
approach is like
very hard for this one so what what if
you asked computer or machine learning
algorithm to control this one and we
write the machine learning algorithm
like basically my statistic about the
rise we cover the data about should we
send these messages right now you
already have probably already have
enough messages or probably you don't
have enough messages and like based on
this like data we decided should be
notified about this event right now or
we should postpone this one so much miss
feature recently and results was quite
surprising like for males
we dropped like total number of messages
13% over 30 percent for females like we
more than half the number of messages we
sent for females like obviously it means
but like for some of em he was not over
much fine but borderline annoying and
interesting fact with like alpha waste
and like class messages for females what
we net 5 and less and in our industry of
is like retention is always linked to
the number of messages like number of
push notification um number of users you
return back but what we learn is with by
sending us messages we actually like
retain and we actually returned back to
our up more females like way more in
Cline's returned back another one is
much longer if you obviously lucky
dating like marching is our core service
like core functionality all about up
have like much in game like when you
match with people you woods
you show interest you save it like I'm
not interested in lucky if both of you
interested is much and the open the
conversation the functionality for you
so for the last couple months we was
focusing on me it's like core experience
like how we can improve this one what is
the main metric for this one for long
time our metric was total number of
matches or number of matches per user
but it said that probably it's like not
the right metric probably we should
focus not on generating more matches but
to distribute them better or to balance
like CVG better so we launched when you
algorithm and results in some countries
hobbies like we operate on 170 markets
some markets like your bet
market smokes slightly less better after
luncheon menu algorithm total number of
matches wasn't changed some from front
perspective of escapee eyes it was like
failed experiment like we spent like
half a year and achieve nothing but like
when I started to look broader on the
broader topic what we noticed is with
actually like 20% of users now have have
much like obviously like if you focusing
on the total number or much as per user
you can have one user with 10 matches
and like a novel user gives 0 in we're
like in the median would be 5o average
would be 5 so like obviously we generate
more matches for the users without them
so like it's now like more users now
ecosystem have much may have and 50%
more wham have yes world which is
sometimes like people like what years on
you and you don't like what years on
them but it can happen but still wake
generate more matches more years was
when we generate engagement for when we
generate events for them so quite
successful from this perspective so like
again what we learned and what you have
far see from these examples is that you
not only needs to focus on some keep
your eyes you you need to like focus
Jeep on were like what's these KPIs
bringing to your ecosystem how whiskey
pies translated to yoga system like what
is the meaningful KPIs for you I have
many many more examples like I choose
only for because I have very very short
amount of time if you want to discuss
that would be somewhere like near the
coffee shop please join me like let's
discuss and like I will share a few more
thank you everyone for your attention
going back to Vinny
you